here's my plan hopefully the sitcom will
stay on for a little bit and during that
time but everybody knows you from MADtv
and who cares how long ago that was and
kicking it old school listen shot in
Canada right yeah Vancouver I remember
because I was supposed to audition and
you cut my rope kicking it out school
school yeah wasn't it Bobby who got it
yeah yeah I did get that and when you
got it I wasn't I'm not making this up I
actually wasn't mad that it was you uh
if it was if they've got like somebody
else had been like who the [ __ ] is like
a Bobby no Bobby I get it like I was
supposed to do barbershop 3 was it 3 and
I was like I went in for the audition
and the director love meaning oh my god
it's gonna be so great when I have such
a good time gonna do breakfast tomorrow
morning we did breakfast and then he
goes okay gran then he was texting me
and then I was on tour and then he was
like hey the studio wants you to come in
and read again and I'm like but I'm on
tour and I can can you push some with
him like what he want me to do different
ID yeah so I went in I did it again and
then I didn't get it they gave it to
that kid that's on on Jay Pharoah snooze
show I know but here's that's what and
then I was like what the [ __ ] is more
you want with a deaf young girl Indian
kid is what I'm talking about
okay what I'm saying is this is that
that's the disconnect is what I'm
talking about
yeah as a director no the director was a
fan I understand that this is what I
would tell I go like this you read for
the director right yeah okay he can act
that in my head I'll be like okay
Russell can I act he's perfect for this
job
you're on tour I get a call from the
studio and they go yeah we don't know
much about this guy Russell we don't
never even heard of whatever what they
might say yeah whatever they say yeah
whatever they probably what you said
yeah and I would probably go yeah well
um here he has his ticket numbers on the
road this is his presence on social I
would do everything I can every factual
thing and go there's no one on planet
Earth in terms of this style of comedy
that's better than this guy
he's the top and I refused to do the
movie without him yeah I don't think it
was that invested in I used to do the
movie without him there's like your fire
he did call me Russell he's called me a
few times subsequently in like always
like man it was out of my hands you know
and you know I don't do that I think if
it was him he wouldn't have called me
and said anything after but you know
what you want to hear the back get back
on this yeah
so then Favreau Jon Favreau puts me in
Jungle Book
oh and then jungle book opened the same
day as barbershop yeah and we kicked
their ass yeah a lot of money hazing yes
somehow there was a victory but also
that director you shouldn't pick up his
phone's I would give him the cold
shoulder no I don't wanna be not you
know play distant that's what I said
yeah a few years now it doesn't matter
you play distant and when you run into
her yeah I don't remember
hmm hey good yeah we you've what's got
the parka yeah I don't remember
did I oh that's cool yeah yeah that's
what I would do you know I did something
else though maybe you are despicable
yeah can I say this a little dream came
true yesterday just FYI I like to show
the voice I love the show the voice and
there's this kid named Noah that's on it
you know a Mac he's killing it whose
team is young he's on a team Jennifer
Hudson stolen by Jennifer from from
Blake I'm friends with Adam oh really
yes I love that show he's such a great
guy he is he seems like a great touch of
cool he's funny too on that show he's a
very funny guy he sends me the most
ridiculous texts periodically tell them
I'm a fan but I know they're on and so I
followed all the voice people I like
their photos I'll mention things you're
doing well anyone respond no no response
oh no likes and nothing right it makes
me angry and you're supporting them yeah
I'm supporting them right I don't like
when I follow people I don't see their
likes I'm like yeah Bobby Leela yeah
and then Noah Mack yes I know my
favorite right and he goes oh my god he
goes oh my god I have a big fan of yours
to me and now he's my number one fan
everyone vote for Noah Mac yeah oh wow
Phil Collins in the air tonight yeah he
killed it tonight
Noah Mac push no I'm at
[Music]